[Musique]
l'autre ventre et politiques à port
marly a été un vrai succès même si
certains tentent encore désespérément de
critiquer notre projet nous pouvons être
fiers de ce que nous avons accompli sur
deux jours se sont créés à 2200m de
toute la france lycéens étudiants et
jeunes actifs qui se sont retrouvés pour
débattre avec nos élus et des
professionnels invités grâce à la
volonté de christian jacob le parti des
républicains donnent la parole aux
jeunes et nous devons la prendre
alors si toi aussi tu as envie d'agir
pour notre pays et pour la république
rejoindre les jeunes républicains c'est
un mouvement sur tout le territoire qui
réunit débat d'idées convivialité et
rampon alors qu'est ce que tu attends
aujourd'hui
[Musique]